قالت حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس ان جيش
الاحتلال ارتكب جريمه جديده بحق النازحين
في خانيونس عبر استهدافه لخمسه مراكز
ايواء بشكل مباشر ومتعمد وبشتى انواع
الاسلحه ما ادى الى سقوط العشرات من
الشهداء والجرحى واضافت حماس في بيان ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي كان قد دعى المواطنين
للجوء الى هذه المراكز وادعى انها امنه
قبل ان يرتكب فيها هذه المجزره البشعه
وحملت حماس الامم المتحده والمجتمع الدولي
المسؤوليه عن استمرار الجرائم الصهيونيه
المروعه بحق المدنيين الامنين كما دعت
حماس كل من سمتها الدول الحره والمخلصه
لقيم العداله والحريه الى التحرك لملاحقه
قاده الاحتلال امام المحاكم الدوليه
ومحاسبتهم على جرائمهم بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني والانسانيه
جمعه y